so often for many of us there are these
scripts or these tapes that are going
through our mind and I call them the
shoulds shoulds lead us to over
commitment and a calendar that is
overstuffed
because you feel guilty and guilt is
what's really behind this should you
feel like you have to do something
either because this is your vision of
what a successful manager does or
because it's a script an old script that
you've heard throughout your life and so
you were listening to voices or to
cultural expectations that might or
might not be true and ultimately miner
might not be in alignment with who you
are and your goals and objectives you
should say yes to this ask to be on this
board you should bake cupcakes from
scratch you should do this it's all
these shoulds well the problem with the
shoulds is that they become a runaway
train and before you know it you've said
yes and overcommitted to so many things
that might or might not be in alignment
with your goals and how you want to live
and run your life so whenever you feel
like you've been hooked by the shoulds I
would suggest that you address them by
using an acronym I call the power no and
by using the power no you step through
the P and the oh and the W and the E and
the R and get really clear on is this
assured that usage say yes to or you
should say no to so the first one is the
purpose questions so what is the purpose
behind this should you know who really
is driving it and what is this should
getting at
and then the Oh stand for the
opportunity because sometimes a should
could be shining a light on an
opportunity so you could be asked to
work in a stretch assignment this could
be a real opportunity for you so you
want to listen and is there an
opportunity potentially and that should
that's going through your head then the
next one is to think about the who who
is behind this should or who is making
this ask of you is it your boss is it
your manager or is it this old script
it's your mom in your head who is this
should have been generated from
and then think about the expectations so
what expectations are coming with this
should is it an expectation that the
star performer at work always does this
or this is what a manager should do just
really think about those expectations
are they yours
are they society's whose are they and
are they really an alignment and then
the last thing I would challenge you to
think about is is it real I mean so is
it really true that you have to bake
cupcakes from scratch that's not true
they're much better cupcakes that are
store-bought for most of us so you're
questioning is it real for you and is it
real and your organization is every time
you say yes to something you're saying
no to something else and the shoulds we
ever commit we say yes more than we say
no and so at the end something suffers
it's either our work or our personal
life